Speaker 1: I have no choice but to admit that
we have a remarkable economic situation right
now.
The situation is not that we will never again
have a recession.
In fact, we almost certainly will unless something
changes permanently about the type of economy
that we have, at some point there will be
a recession or worse, because that's the way
that things have worked for a very long time.
But when we look at the latest inflation numbers
and we look at all of the other data that
we have, it is quite an extraordinary situation.
We have new inflation numbers out today.
It's July, so the numbers are from June.
And for the 12 month period ending in June
of 2023 and year over year, inflation is down
to 3%.
3%.
I have been talking about for over a year
now.
I've been saying I believe that by August
of 23, inflation will be down to the low fours
or the high threes, which would be a dramatic
improvement from where it was a year and a
half ago.
I don't know anything.
It was just my sense of the direction things
were going and I actually was too conservative
in my estimate.
Inflation.
Consumer prices in June rose at slowest annual
rate since March of 2021, according to the
latest data from the Bureau of Labor Statistics.
Now, these right wingers who just don't like
these numbers will say, you can't believe
these numbers.
That's not real.
Okay.
Well, when when you like the numbers, you
believe the numbers from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics and now the goal.
But eggs are expensive.
I saw the other day we don't judge these numbers
by what one person, season one grocery store.
This is actually a metric that is extraordinarily
detailed and nuanced.
The consumer price index went up 0.2% last
month and that prior year number, it is now
a 3% increase, a 3% increase as of last month.
We had a 4% year over year increase.
We are now down to a 3% year over year increase.
These are really good numbers.
And it is not just inflation in a vacuum that
looks really good.
And I'll come back to what we mean when we
say inflation looks good, wages are rising
and are now higher than they were before the
pandemic.
Inflation adjusted again.
The detractors, the the MAGA pessimists will
say, well, sure, nominally wages are higher,
but inflation has been crazy.
No, no, no, no, no.
Inflation adjusted wages, real wages are now
higher than they were before the pandemic.
If you look at the G7 countries, the U.S.
has the lowest inflation of all, all of them.
If you look at gas prices, gas prices are
now down about a buck 50 a gallon.
The unemployment rate is at 3.6%.
That is under 4% for the longest stretch in
50 years, 50 years.
And of course, they will come back and they
will say, oh, but a lot of these are low quality
jobs or a lot of people have stopped looking
for work.
These are always things that can be said.
It's the way these metrics work.
You can't only say that when it's to your
advantage.
These are the real numbers.
Now, let's talk about inflation a little bit.
I want to remind you that the target for inflation
is not zero.
The target for inflation is considered to
be 2%.
We're basically there.
We're at 3%.
The target is 2%.
So we are getting down to an inflation level.
That is what you would want for what would
be considered by traditional economic measures,
a good inflation number.
Let me remind you why.
And I know that there are people who have
heard me say this before, but I do think it's
it's such an important basic economic concept
to understand that I want to explain it again.
If inflation is really high, we know why that's
bad.
People can't afford stuff.
If inflation is 8% and wages are only up 2%,
things become unaffordable.
So people stop buying them, which is bad for
businesses.
So businesses have to lay people off and then
the people they lay off don't have money to
buy things.
So then more businesses have to lay people
off.
So very high inflation.
It's pretty self-evident why that's bad.
Some people might say, well, shouldn't we
want zero inflation or even deflation?
Prices coming down would be so great everybody
can afford what they want.
Wrong.
If there is a deflationary situation, you
would expect things to be cheaper in the future
than they are now.
And so save for absolute necessities like
food, you need food to survive.
If you expect prices to be lower in the future,
you would delay economic activity.
If I'm looking at a car and I say, Well, the
car is going to be 3% cheaper in six months,
I wouldn't buy it.
And it has a similar effect as things being
on affordably expensive, which is you're not
buying and that's bad for businesses.
They lay off workers and you have the same
thing.
The reason that by traditional economic measures
we say 2% inflation roughly is what we want
is that that 2% inflation is what drives economic
growth and expansion.
Now, of course, when we step out of this traditional
economic analysis, we say, well, the planet
is of limited size and resources.
You can't have indefinite growth.
And that is also theoretically true.
And in some sense it's practically true.
Before we get to that point, we may be off
to mining asteroids or who knows what.
So it starts to get a little theoretical and
philosophical.
But that's the reason why a little bit of
inflation is considered good.
I also want to remind you there are many aspects
to inflation that have nothing to do with
the president.
So I'm not here to tell you we're going to
bow and pray at the altar of Joe Biden.
That would be because of what we're seeing,
much the same way that it wasn't exclusively
Trump's fault that inflation was high.
There are many aspects to inflation that don't
relate to the president.
This includes changes to the money supply,
supply and demand shocks like, for example,
natural disasters, COVID, whatever the case
may be, expectations about inflation become
self-fulfilling prophecies.
These things are bigger than the president.
And remember, inflation is coming down in
all G7 countries, but it's coming down more
in the United States.
What presidents can do is fiscal policy like
government spending, taxation, etc., and indirectly
money, monetary policy.
Remember, the president doesn't control monetary
policy directly.
The Fed does.
But the president does decide who is in charge
at the Fed.
So no reason to play political games, no reason
to sugarcoat or to do Sky is falling stuff.
These numbers are what they are.
They only slightly relate to Joe Biden, but
this is a good sign.
Overall, doesn't mean it's a perfect economy,
doesn't mean there won't be a downturn at
some point in the future